Let's review a little bit of
what we know about exponents.
So if I were to have 3 to
the second power times 3
to the third power,
what does that equal?
Well, we could expand
it out just as a review.
3 to the second power-- well,
that's going to be 3 times 3.
And then 3 to the
third power-- we're
going to multiply it by
3 to the third power--
is going to be 3
times 3 times 3.
So what is this
going to be equal to?
Well, this is going to be equal
to 3 to the 2 plus 3 power.
And this comes straight
out of what an exponent is.
We're taking two 3's and
multiplying it together.
And then we're going to
multiply that with three 3's
being multiplied together.
So you're going to end up
with 2 plus 3, or five,
3's being multiplied together.
So this, of course, is
going to be equal to 3
to the fifth power.
And that's a little
bit of review.
And this is one of the
core exponent properties.
If you have the same base
multiplied to exponents,
and you're taking the product
of those two expressions,
you can essentially, or you
do, just add the exponents.
3 to some exponent times
3 to some other exponent
is going to be 3 to the
sum of those two exponents.
So that's kind of
interesting, but now
let's use this property
right over here
to try to think about what a
negative exponent should be.
So we're going to try to think
about what should-- let's just
say 3 to the negative 2 power--
what should this be equal to?
And I encourage you to pause
this video and think about it.
Think about, what should
this be equal to if we
want this property
to hold, that if you
have the same base raised
to different exponents,
and you're taking the product
of those two expressions,
that you can take that base to
the sum of those two exponents.
Well, let's try a
little experiment here.
What should 3 squared times
3 to the negative 2 power be?
What should this be equal to?
Well, if we want to keep
this property going,
this should be equal
to 3 to the 2 plus
negative 2 power, which, of
course, would be equal to 3
to the 0-th power.
And any non-zero number
to the 0-th power
is going to be equal to 1.
So this should be equal to 1.
So we should define 3 to
the negative 2 in some way
so that 3 squared times
3 to the negative 2
should be equal to 1.
We need to do that if we want
this property to hold right
over there.
So let's just think about
what 3 to the negative 2
should actually be.
So we want this to equal 1.
Let me copy and paste that
so that we can manipulate it
a little bit algebraically.
All right.
So we have that on one side.
We want that to be equal to 1.
And let me clean
this up a little bit.
We want that to be equal to 1.
So to define 3 to
the negative 2,
or to think about what 3 to
the negative 2 should be,
let's divide both
sides by 3 squared.
Let's divide both sides by that.
So let me copy that.
So we're going to divide
this side by that,
and we're going to
divide this side by that.
And let me draw a line so that
you know that we're dividing.
So we're going to
divide the left hand
by that and the
right hand by that.
Well, 3 squared over 3
squared-- those cancel out.
And now we get a really
interesting result.
We get that 3 to
the negative 2 power
should be equal to 1 over
3 to the second power.
And I really want you to
internalize this right over
here.
You have something to
the negative power,
to the negative 2
power, in this case.
That's equal to 1 over 3
to the positive version
of that exponent.
And this is true in general.
In the next video, we'll
use a very similar argument
to prove this for any non-zero
base and any exponent,
that raising it to
the negative should
be-- if you want this
exponent property to hold,
that you would add the
exponents when we're
taking the product of
the same base raised
to different exponents.
If you want that
property to hold,
when you raise something
to the negative exponent,
it should be 1 over
that base raised
to the positive version
of that exponent.
So 3 to the negative
2 power is 1 over 3
squared, which is equal to 1/9.